[Musique]
on est adroit mais leur dans le sud-est
de l'alberta c'est la capitale mondiale
des dinosaures ou en tout cas c'est
comme ça que la ville aime se présenter
ici il ya un musée dédié à la
paléontologie des bancs publics qui
évoque le film le parc jurassique et un
énorme tyrannosaure qui accueille les
enfants dans sa mâchoire j'ai jamais
rien c'est aussi la capitale du
conservatisme au canada parce qu'en
octobre dernier 86 % les électeurs ici
ont voté pour le parti de rire
c'est le cas de sonia grimm qui
travaillent dans ce magasin de souvenirs
où elle vend des fossiles en tout genre
sonia a l'impression d'être regardé dos
quand elles défendent secteur pétrolier
albertain les gens ailleurs au canada
pense qu'on est des dinosaures qu'on
n'est pas capable d'évoluer avec le
temps mais nous on voit les
automobilistes qui continuent de
consommer de l'essence on voit le
secteur pétrolier qui est en plein boom
aux états unis et on se demande pourquoi
est ce que nous on doit changer et pas
et cet argument on l'entend beaucoup en
ce moment en alberta des électeurs kids
id la demande mondiale en pétrole va
continuer d'augmenter dans les
prochaines années
pourquoi alors est-ce qu'on laisserait
d'autres pays en profiter plutôt que le
canada sonia d'ailleurs ne crois pas que
le pétrole des sables bitumineux soit
plus sale que les autres le pétrole
albertain pourquoi serait-il pire
qu'ailleurs nogaye s'ils travaillent
fort ce sont de bons employés à quelques
coins de rue de là la mairesse de droit
mais ne nous montre des magasins qui ont
fermé depuis la chute des prix du brut
en 2014 elle aussi pense que les
canadiens devraient être plus fiers de
leurs secteurs énergétiques charbon or
il faut acheter local
pourquoi est ce que les provinces de
l'est se procure du pétrole de pays
dictatoriaux alors qu'on a les
ressources ici
quand on lui précise que la majorité de
l'essence consommée au québec et en
ontario ne vient plus de l'arabie
saoudite mais bien du canada et des
états unis
la mairesse évoque rapidement une autre
source de frustration la péréquation
oui ce match juste à côté d'elle un
camionneur s'en prend plus directement
aux québécois de ils prennent notre
argent qu'on pourrait utiliser pour nos
routes et nos soins de santé ils
utilisent pour se remplir les poches
on n'est pas loin de ce que jason kenny
disait récemment conférence de presse le
québec a déposé une budget un budget
équilibré
parce que le québec reçoit 13 millions $
dont les paiements de péréquation
selon cette professeure retraitée
l'université calgary
les albertains ont du mal à accepter que
les prix du pétrole ne sont plus ce
qu'ils étaient et leur gouvernement n'a
pas suffisamment mis d'argent de côté
durant les années poules dindes et
comptait de la crise évidemment on va se
chercher un coupable
on va chercher un bouc émissaire il faut
se trouver quelqu'un qui n'est facile à
identifier qui présente déjà si vous
voulez une suite qui est défini alors le
québec
sauf que le québec et la péréquation ne
peuvent pas être tenu responsable de
tous les problèmes de l'alberta 17
autres experts
si l'alberta ne reçoit pas de
péréquation c'est parce que c'est ça
reste la province la plus riche au pays
et que par conséquent sa capacité
fiscale sa capacité de collecter de
l'argent des contribuables est plus
élevé que la moyenne nationale
car malgré la chute des prix du pétrole
le pib par habitant en alberta tourne
autour de 80 mille dollars alors qu'il
nique de 60 mille dollars en ontario et
de 52 mille dollars au québec
comment alors est-ce que justin trudeau
on peut montrer qu'il est à l'écouté des
albertains qui comprend leur colère
quand cette colère est en partie basé
sur des mythes à côté c'est toujours
difficile de combattre des mythes des
fausses informations surtout lorsqu'elle
est même de la bouche de d'élus
politiques et même de premier ministre
comme jason kenny alors il faut
certainement pour autant avoir trouvé
des porte parole dans l'ouest essayer de
contourner
parfois jason kenny est allé directement
à la population albertaine
une tâche qui s'annonce énorme surtout
dans la ville des dinosaures où l'on
continue de voir justin trudeau est lé
québec comme des profiteurs et des gens
qui veulent faire disparaître un mode de
vie encore centré sur le pétrole ici
l'heure incertain radio canada